the whole progress of physics is to
start with our everyday experience and
to analyze it and look at it and look
for deviations from it so the very
nature of actually really all the
Natural Sciences but certainly of
physics is to really get away from our
experience so the things physics comes
up with are just kind of weird they were
going to be because that's just how the
world operates that's how physics make
sense of the world subatomic particles
we can't see them directly at least but
we know they're there we can actually do
thought experiments about the things we
do see and deduce their existence so
already even with just at them an
example we've gone insured beyond our
direct experience and a hundred years
ago or so people doubted the existence
I've Adams a lot of loan of sub atomic
particles nonlocality spooky action at
the distances very much in that in that
mold it's taking us yet further away
from our experience and therefore we
expect it to be weird it should be weird
that's why physics is flattened if they
were just reproducing the things we
already knew I mean who really would
care it's kind of fun because it's it's
taking us beyond our experience it's
transcending our daily experience into
this new realm that is is weird
and as other scientists have said you
expect it in fact if the theory isn't
weird
you kind of doubt it because you might
worry that your own biases are intruding
into the into the theory and causing you
to think the world is a certain way when
you're not listening to the way the
world actually is so weirdness is in a
sense a test of a theory now that said
you can't just sit here and kind of just
daydream or over a beer come up with
more and more weird things they have to
somehow connect back to what we do
observe and that's really the challenge
of this whole field is well with
subatomic particles how do they connect
with what we do see so they're not just
weirdness for weirdness sake it's
weirdness in a way that actually relates
ultimately back to what we see and so
has to be with spooky action at a
distance with nonlocality
ultimately we get locality vac the
quality of space step governs our lives
has to emerge and has to come out of the
non locality that seems to reside at the
very fabric you know the deepest levels
of the universe one instinct you might
have when you learn about these
connections among different particles
and different objects in the universe is
aha maybe that explains telepathy
maybe that allows psychic powers maybe
that will let us operate from Hogwarts
into London or one of these things you
want would want to do and unfortunately
or actually I'll come back to in a sense
fortunately that's not really possible
it's it's kind of unfortunate cuz you
kind of would want those magical
abilities but it's a case of you have to
be careful what you wish for so for
example suppose I could sit on my couch
and just buy psychic action get the Mets
to win the World Series so wouldn't we
want that but unfortunately all the
other baseball teams would also have
that psychic ability and we'd have this
huge battle of psychic wits taking place
on the among the couch potatoes of the
world so the baseball game itself in
that case would be irrelevant in a more
broad sense our very existence depends
on space
we're spatial creatures we even have it
a certain little volume of space we have
a shape we have various spatial
properties and if space didn't exist we
couldn't exist so we would kind of want
the psychic powers but if we had them
that would actually kind of undermine
the very conditions of our own existence